يشعر الأشخاص العالقون في سياراتهم في
موقع الاختبار هذا في شمال أوغدن
بالإحباط وهم ينتظرون
تدفق بعضهم في الشارع
راغبين في معرفة
ما إذا كان لديهم كوفيد 19.
تأخير
المسعفين الذين يحاولون إنقاذ حياة
رجل يبلغ من العمر 71 عامًا لم يكن مستجيبًا
بحلول الوقت الذي وصل فيه إلى الخيمة لإجراء
الاختبار ، فمن السابق لأوانه القول ما إذا كان قد
مات بسبب فيروس كورونا الذي لم
نشخصه في هذا المجال ،
لذا فإن مهمتنا هي  لمجرد معالجة الأعراض
التي نراها في
العلامات التي نراها ، هل تعتقد أن هناك
عددًا كافيًا من الموظفين للتعامل مع جميع هؤلاء المرضى في أي يوم معين ، فأنت لا تعرف عدد المرضى الذين
سيحضرون للاختبار ،
فهذا ليس موقفًا لإعادة الجدولة
نيل بيروبي ، عمدة شمال أوغدن ، هو
أيضًا عضو في مجلس
أمناء إنترماونتين
، قال إنه لا يريد التحدث
نيابة عن المستشفى ، لكنه يصف
الحالة
المقلقة بما أفهمه أنه كان
مقيمًا في إحدى الرعاية.
منشأة وكان يبحث عن
إجراء كان بحاجة إلى إجرائه
قبل أن يتمكن من دخول المستشفى أو
العيادة الخارجية
لإجراء العملية ، فإما أن أقول
إنه سيكون من المؤسف جدًا محاولة
إلقاء اللوم على ما حدث
هنا القلق والخوف من ذلك  موجود في
مجتمعاتنا
فقط عندما نقفز إلى
استنتاجات يقول المسعفون عند
وصولهم أن الرجل كان يعاني من سكتة
قلبية تنفسية والتي يمكن أن تكون ناجمة
عن أي عدد من الأشياء
بما في ذلك النوبة القلبية أو
مضاعفات فيروس كوفيد 19 ،
فكيف حدث هذا إلى أين
هل حصلت على هذه فكرة رائعة من
أين حصلت على فكرة مثل الانتظار لمدة
دقيقة ، حسنًا ،
سأعمل هنا حتى أتمكن من رؤيتهم ،
لقد طلبت
في البداية في بداية مارس 10 مارس على
وجه الدقة
أنا في الواقع  اتصلت بمركز رعاية الذاكرة
وقلت ما الذي يمكنني فعله ، يجب أن
يكون هناك طريقة للدخول ، هل يمكنني
التطوع ،
هل يمكنني الحصول على وظيفة وقد قالوا نوعًا ما
دعونا نرى نوعًا ما  ما يحدث هنا ،
نحن
جميعًا نأمل أن هذا لن
يستمر طويلًا جدًا ،
ومع بدء الوقت وبدأت في
الحصول على صوت أكثر قليلاً
حول أننا بحاجة إلى القيام بشيء ما ، فهذا
موقف مروع حقًا
خارج  لقد اتصلوا بي باللون الأزرق ، لذلك أنا
محظوظ بشكل لا يصدق لأن لدي قلعة الورد
، وأقول في الواقع
هل ترغب في الحصول على وظيفة لدينا وظيفة
بدوام جزئي متاحة
، فهذه تهانينا الرائعة
على مثابرتك على ذلك
وبعد ذلك  أعطني فكرة عن أنك
تعرف نوع الاهتمام
والرعاية التي شعرت بها وكأنك تعرف
أن زوجك سيفتقده
بسبب عدم وجودك لزيارته ، لماذا
كان من المهم جدًا بالنسبة لك تولي هذه
الوظيفة حتى تتمكن من ذلك
يجب أن تعرف أن تكون داخل الجدران لرؤيتها
مرضى الخرف يحتاجون إلى اللمس يحتاجون إلى
رعاية عاطفية يحتاجون إلى اتصال
وإذا لم يكن لديهم هذا الاتصال
فإن دماغهم
يموت ببطء شديد وببطء ليس هو الكلمة الصحيحة
وهذا ما يحدث عادة  يحدث عندما
يكونون في هذا الموقف ، فإنه
يزيد من سرعة ذلك بسرعة ، ولذا
كان قلقي هو
أنه لا يتم لمسه ، فهو لا
يحتضن أنه لا يحصل على
الاتصالات وهذا هو السبب حقًا في
أنني وضعته هناك من أجل
الجانب الاجتماعي من  لقد
كان ستيف دائمًا اجتماعيًا بشكل لا يصدق
ويجب أن يكون حول الأشخاص
ويجب أن يكون لديه هذا الاتصال ،
فهناك مجموعة من 50 60
شخصًا يرقصون للتو على حبل عشرات
الشباب الذين شوهدوا في حفل في مقاطعة أوسيولا بفلوريدا مسؤولو عمدة الشرطة أخبروا شبكة
CNN التابعة
الذين يعتقدون أن مثل هذه الأحزاب أدت
إلى ارتفاع في حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا في تلك
المنطقة
في حفلات الشباب في ميشيغان
في بلدات سيلين وبحيرة الشعلة ،
يقول المسؤولون إنَّها
انفجرت في عشرات حالات
الطمع ، لكن هذا ليس أسوأ ما
في الأمر بينما بعض الأطراف  يحضرها
الشباب الذين يعتقدون ببساطة أنهم لن
يصابوا
بأطراف أخرى يبدو أنه تم استضافتهم من
قبل أشخاص يعرفون
أنهم مصابون أو حضروا  من قبل الأشخاص الذين
يحاولون الإصابة بالعدوى ،
يقول المسؤولون المحليون إن دفع
كبار الخبراء الأمريكيين في الأمراض المعدية
إلى الشك عندما أسمع عن هذه
الحفلات الطمعية
، فأنت تعلم فقط أنه يجعل رأسي يدور
لأنه عندما تصاب بالعدوى ، فإن
ما تفعله هو أنك لست في
فراغ أنت جزء
من انتشار تفشي المرض ،
وضعت الدكتورة جين أبليبي ، كبيرة المسؤولين الطبيين في
مستشفى ميثوديست في سان
أنطونيو ، رسالة مسجلة بالفيديو في
الأيام الأخيرة حول مريضة تبلغ من العمر 30 عامًا في المستشفى
التي قالت إنها اعترفت بحضور
حفل مرغوب فيه
هذه حفلة أقامها شخص
تم تشخيصه بفيروس الكود
والفكر هو أن الناس
يجتمعون ليروا ما إذا كان الفيروس
حقيقيًا وإذا أصيب أي
شخص قبل وفاة المريض مباشرة ، نظروا
إلى ممرضتهم وقالوا
إنني فعلت ذلك  خطأ اعتقدت أن هذا
كان خدعة ولكن ليس
رئيس بلدية سان أنطونيو أكد هذه
الحالة في مقابلة مع
CNN وقدم المزيد من التفاصيل التي اعتقدوا أنها
كانت لا تقهر.  لا
تؤثر عليهم
كطريقة تعرفها لإثبات
وجهة نظرهم ، وللأسف بعد خمسة أيام ،
كان هذا
حفلًا ليوم تذكاريًا في البحيرة بعد خمسة أيام ، وقد تسبب
هذا الشاب في مرض المسؤولين في
توسكالوسا ألاباما وتحدثوا مؤخرًا عن
المعلومات التي تلقوها عن الشباب.
يبدو أن الأشخاص يقيمون
حفلات مرغوبة في تلك المدينة ، حيث
يقوم عضو في مجلس المدينة بنقل روايات
عن مسابقات شنيعة ،
فهم يضعون المال في
وعاء ويحاولون عمداً
التستر على الشخص الذي يطمع
ويبدو أن كل من يتعامل معه في البداية
يحصل على القدر
قال أحد الخبراء الذين اتصلوا بهم من قبل مسؤولي الصحة في CNN في ألاباما وسان أنطونيو إنهم
حققوا في التقارير لكنهم لم يتمكنوا من
تأكيد أو نفي وجود
أطراف مطمعة في مناطقهم على الرغم من أن
الشباب يبدو أنهم أقل
عرضة للإصابة بمرض خطير أو الوفاة من
فيروس كورونا.
ليس من الكلمات
أن يلعبوا لعبة الروليت الروسية مع
حياتهم الخاصة
أو حياة الآخرين الذين قد
يصيبون والديهم  r أجدادهم
أو معلميهم أو صاحب العمل الذين قد يكونون فوق
سن 65 عامًا والذين قد يكون
لديهم حالة كامنة
وسيموتون ، لا يمكنني التفكير في أي شيء أكثر
غباءً
من الذهاب إلى حفلة كوفنت دكتور تشارلز
لوكوود ويقول خبراء آخرون  يجب على
الشباب الذين قد يذهبون إلى هذه الحفلات
أن يتذكروا أيضًا أنه حتى لو
أصيبوا بـ covet
19 وتعافوا منه ، فقد يتسبب ذلك في
مضاعفات لهم
في وقت لاحق من الحياة ، مثل أمراض الكلى أو
قصور القلب
أو أمراض الرئة أو التعب المزمن.